for cornwall's holidaymakers
there are some unusual sights at the
seaside
royal navy ships patrol carbus bay
as police zoom past on jet skis while on
the beach
military radar scan the skies after
months of preparation
thousands of delegates journalists and
police are here
as the g7 summit begins are you ready
yes we are ready we've been planning
this for months now
it's the biggest police and security
event in england this year
so as you can imagine we have big
numbers to help us police this
six and a half thousand officers have
come to cornwall from
every force in the country a thousand
are having to stay on a cruise ship
the summit has turned cornish coves into
lockdown zones
with locals already feeling the impact
it
shouldn't have been done now because of
covered and the fact
that they should have just held it on
zoom and did it that way
my business is shutting down thursday
friday saturday sunday it's not going to
work
we'll pack up wednesday evening and then
we'll come back on monday
you uh give biden an ice cream if he
comes i would
yeah i'm boris yeah they're welcome
while there will be disruption for some
the summit is a sweet deal
the official g7 chocolate bar made in
the cornish town of wadebridge
had to get government approval got an
email first
just a out of the blue from one of the
offices in whitehall
they specified they wanted milk
chocolate flavoured with sea salt
covid and climate change are top of the
agenda here
both issues that impact this county the
leaders of some of the richest
countries in the world will be on this
beach at the weekend and it's thought
the summit will bring in around 50
million pounds
into cornwall the question is just how
much
real people living here will actually
see of that cash
camborne is 10 miles from the summit and
one of the poorest
parts of cornwall i think it's just a
quick flashing pound of money
yeah yeah we won't get nothing out of it
i don't think
cambodn and other places have got their
their problems
and i think the money could be better
spent
there are plenty of protests planned
this weekend
the eyes of the world on all of these
leaders
as they gather in this corner of
cornwall
dan white says sky news in carbus bay